[Musica]
mica lo so perché ti vengono a trovare i
ricordi ogni tanto bussano alla memoria
arrivano ti raccontano una storia e la
storia che vi sto per raccontare una
storia che inizia in mezzo al mare
una storia che io ho letto su uno
scoglio davanti al mare al mio mare il
giorno in cui ho capito davvero che
avevamo superato ogni limite
ricordo perfettamente l'anno era
l'estate nel 2015
io ero sul mio scoglio
ora il mio scoglio a una parte in questa
storia perché voi forse non lo sapete ma
il mio uno scoglio che cammina non sto
scherzando
alcuni anni fa per arrivare al mio
scoglio bisogna valutare dopo qualche
anno il mio scoglio è arrivato a riva e
adesso ci può essere tranquillamente con
una tazza di caffe un libro da leggere
il mio scoglio ha camminato dicono che
sia colpa del cambiamento climatico pare
che la crisi climatica faccia a
sciogliere i ghiacciai a faccia a
camminare gli scogli io ne ho le prove
comunque era l'estate del 2015 e sul mio
scoglio stavo leggendo la storia di
ellen ellen una giovane velista inglese
che aveva cambiato radicalmente il modo
di pensare all'economia non sto
sbagliando e non aveva 24 23 anni quando
fece realizzò il suo sogno della bambina
e fece il giro del mondo in barca
circumnavigando il pianeta battendo il
record di velocità da sola in barca 56
57 mila km 26 27 mila miglia marine ma
quello che importa e lo voglio leggere
ai record 71 giorni 14 ore 18 minuti e
33 secondi
io ovviamente non lo so cosa si prova a
stare in mare da soli per 71 giorni 14
ore e 18 minuti e 33 secondi
e nemmeno so cosa si provi a stare in
mare per 71 notti svegliandosi a
intermittenza ogni 20 minuti dalla
doveva fare perché doveva controllare
che tutto fosse a posto
bastava il timone che cambiava un attimo
il grado bastava sbagliare la rotta
sbagliava bastava il vento bastava
qualche piccolo particolare
e sarebbe andato a fuori rotta e andando
fuori rotta avrebbe cambiato anche il
suo destino
quindi ellen di notte si svegliava ogni
20 minuti e facendo questo per 71 a
notti lei capisce una cosa fondamentale
capisce l'importanza delle risorse le
risorse
tutto quello che le serviva tutto quello
di cui aveva bisogno era sulla sua barca
ma la sua barca era un mondo finito è un
mondo piccolo a se lei sbagliava usare
le sue risorse avrebbe sbagliato la sua
navigazione in quelle notti helen
capisce che e dall'economia globale del
mondo che stava sbagliando rotta helen
capisce che il mondo stava sprecando le
sue risorse perché anche il mondo non
era in finito anche il mondo era finito
era proprio come la sua barca era solo
molto più grande dopo qualche anno nel
2010 ellen von da una fondazione che
porta il suo nome la lm cartour
fondation che ha come scopo quello di
parlare di economia circolare a tutti i
governi a tutte le aziende del mondo
grazie ad ellen il mondo inizia a
conoscere l'economia circolare ma cos'è
l'economia circolare
e soprattutto quale differenza c'è
quell'economia che conosciamo la
cosiddetta economia lineare non voglio
non voglio tediarvi con teorie di
economia politica macromicro economia
con le teorie liberiste di milton
friedman dell'economia sociale di keynes
no non voglio fare questo del racconto
così
immaginate una linea retta molto
semplice da una parte della linea retta
c'è l'uomo che produce dall'altra parte
della linea retta
c'è l'uomo che consuma scopo dell'uomo
che produce inventarsi produrle qualcosa
che sia interessante per l'uomo che
consuma e per arrivare velocemente
all'uomo che consuma roma che produce
cosa fa progetta i suoi prodotti di
costruisce usa la materia che gli serve
per costruirla usa l'energia che gli
serve per costruire produce un sacco di
rifiuti
quelli li mette da parte non solo per
lui così interessanti in quel momento è
più interessante che quello che produce
arrivi velocemente e bene al suo
consumatore invest in logistica investi
in comunicazione investe in marketing
arriva nei punti di vendita
il suo sogno è il moltiplicarsi
all'infinito dell'uomo che consuma
c'è qualcosa di sbagliato in tutto
questo apparentemente no
in pratica è tutto sbagliato perché
improvvisamente all'uomo che produce gli
dicono due cose una la sapeva ma faceva
finta di non saperla un'altra nulla
sapeva quella che sapeva faceva finta di
non sapere è molto semplice mettendo
sotto la polvere della produzione
rifiuti
avevamo devastato il pianeta e questo
lui lo sapeva
ma una cosa che non sapeva quella più
grave di tutti per lui era che il suo
problema non ce l'aveva a valle non ce
l'aveva nel moltiplicare all'infinito il
numero dei consumatori
questa sia sicav è il prodotto giusto la
pubblicità giusta il prezzo giusto la
qualità giusta ce l'avrebbe fatta
il suo problema ce l'aveva alle spalle
ce l'aveva a monte all'uomo che produce
gli viene detto attenzione la materia
che ti serve per produrre qualunque cosa
sta finendo in alcuni casi è già finita
game over gioco finito non c'è più
niente da fare per fortuna arriva
l'economia circolare arriva l'economia
che l aveva immaginato con la notte in
barca un'economia capace di rigenerarsi
da sola anima un'economia che sa
costruire l'infinito e come ci riesce
deve fare una cosa apparentemente
semplice in pratica complicatissima deve
restituire la materia al pianeta deve
restituire al pianeta tutto quello che
ha usato per fabbricare quello di cui ha
bisogno e lo non è più una linea retta
è un circolo poco importa se quella
materia che verrà recuperata alla fine
del circolo servirà a rifare la stessa
cosa o servirà a fare altre cose ma deve
essere recuperata l'economia circolari
non esistono più i rifiuti brutta parola
e rifiuti i nostri nonni i nostri
bisnonni non sappiamo nemmeno cosa fosse
un rifiuto sentiti come è brutta come
parola lontana cresciuto una cosa che ti
mette subito distanza l'economia
circolare rigenera quello che nel gergo
si chiama materia prima seconda e cioè
dagli scarti di produzione si trovano
elementi e materie che servono per
produrre altre cose da cosa rinasce cosa
questa e l'economia
scolare ma torniamo sullo scoglio il mio
scoglio che cammina
era l'estate nel 2015
io leggevo la storia di ellen e pensavo
ma io lo posso fare un esempio di
economia circolare io lo posso fare un
esempio di economia che si rigenera da
sola come ho detto all'inizio di questa
storia
i ricordi arrivano ti vengono a trovare
improvvisamente ti raccontano una storia
e arrivo al ricordo giusto su quello
scoglio ricordo era molto lontano del
tempo non ero più piccolo ma era ancora
in quell'età in cui non sai cosa
significa crescere periodo magico in cui
le cose che accadono assumono
significati che ti porterà dietro per
tutta la vita
ero a casa a casa mia
mia madre ogni giovedì apriva il
frigorifero dentro il frigorifero
prendiamo una ciotola misteriosa che era
coperta con un panno la metteva sul
tavolo sulla media di legno metteva le
mani in questo ciotole tirano fuori
dalla ciotola quasi tutto il suo
contenuto non tutto quasi tutto il suo
contenuto
lo metteva sulla mafia rimetteva nella
ciotola un po di farina un po d'acqua e
altre cose misteriose che faceva
ricopriva la ciotola rimetteva nel
frigorifero
poi sulla maglia iniziava ad impastare
io gli dicevo mamma cosa stai facendo
bene mi rispondeva sto rinnovando il
lievito madre per fare il pane
ovviamente io non riuscivo a dare un
significato pieno alla cosa che stava
facendo però la vedevo alla fine questo
impasto lo metteva dentro una zuppiera
molto grande e ci mettiamo anche lì una
coperta sopra questa schiera
perché bisogna tenere il legame al caldo
dice voleva mele lo chiamava così
l'impasto nel frattempo mio padre in
giardino avevamo un bellissimo forno a
legna aveva acceso il formale
il legame cresceva usciva dalla zuppiera
spostava il panno questo punto era
pronto
mia madre lo prendeva faceva delle con
le mani costruita il pane costruiva la
forma del pane e quella sera il pane
caldo uscito dal forno arrivava sulla
nostra tavola
e rendeva grazie alla propria madre che
era nella ciotola del frigorifero
io oggi so che quella e l'economia
circolare e l'economia circolare perché
la materia ricostruiva in eterno la
materia mia madre quella ciotola ce l'ha
ancora nel suo frigorifero è sempre
quella e ogni giovedì ha sempre di fatto
il pane ma com'è possibile che accada un
miracolo di questo tipo per fare in modo
che l'economia circolare accada tutti
devi prendere cura della materia la devi
proteggere se non te ne prendi cura e
non la protegge la materia non ti darà
l'infinito di cui tu hai bisogno
quel giorno su quello scoglio scrissi
una frase che me la voglio leggere
perché l'economia circolare non è una
scelta possibile di futuro ma l'unico
futuro possibile
quella frase oggi è diventata parte del
mio lavoro
era l'estate del 2015 è importante
ricordarcelo perché il 2015 l'anno in
cui è cambiata la consapevolezza del
mondo rispetto ai temi della
sostenibilità ambientale ed economica
accadono tre cose parte a parte la mia
avventura sullo scoglio che cammina
accadono tre cose la prima
papà francesco pubblica la sua enciclica
laudato sì in quell enciclica il papa si
scaglia contro quella che definisce la
cultura dello spreco dice che noi
abbiamo abbandonato la terra e l'abbiamo
trasformata in un enorme deposito di
immondizia e ditemi cosa
quale futuro si può costruire un
deposito di immondizia negli stessi mesi
l'onu seconda cosa varrà gli esigenza i
17 obiettivi di sostenibilità che quasi
tutti i governi del mondo sottoscrivono
per fermare il riscaldamento del pianeta
per trovare energie rinnovabili per
liberarci dalla dittatura del carbone ed
energia fossile le famose da te che
tutti quanti ormai conosciamo gli
obiettivi al 2030 al 2050
accade anche una terza cosa un signore
che si chiama larry fink uno degli
uomini più potenti del mondo seo del
fondo di investimento blackrock uno dei
fondi più grandi del pianeta scrive una
lettera agli amministratori delegati del
suo gruppo
una lettera per dirgli una cosa molto
semplice gli dice amici miei
d'ora in avanti occuparsi e
sostenibilità ambientale occuparsi di
sostenibilità sociale occuparsi del
risparmio di materia non è più una
questione etica non è più una questione
che mettete nelle vostre brochure
aziendali per dire quanto siete bravi
quando siete buoni se noi non ci
occupiamo della sostenibilità scrive
larry fink non c'è più possibilità di
generare il profitto da quel giorno la
sostenibilità diventa un fattore
competitivo le imprese
tutti sanno che avranno un futuro solo
se saranno sostenibile la più importante
autorità religiosa la più importante
autorità pubblica la più importante
autorità finanziaria dicono le stesse
cose con le stesse parole nelle stesse
settimane dal 2015
parlavi di economia circolare significa
parlare di tutto ma significa davvero
parlare di tutto significa parlare del
lavoro della formazione di come
progettiamo le cose che usiamo di come
le proteggiamo nelle scatole nel
packaging significa occuparsi di energia
significa occuparsi dell'abitare
significa occuparsi di moda ad esempio
noi adesso quell'economia circolare
sappiamo che è sufficiente una piccola
molecola naturale che messa contatto con
gli scarti di lavorazione dell'atto con
le bucce delle arance costruisce dei
tessuti non ci potremo vestire di latte
e ci possiamo messi lì di arance
l'economia circolare ha sancito il
diritto proclamato dall'europa agli usa
la riparazione degli oggetti che noi
abbiamo noi abbiamo il diritto di poter
aggiustare i nostri telefonini
abbiamo il diritto di poter aggiustare
le nostre stampanti abbiamo il diritto
di poter aggiustare i nostri computer
noi dobbiamo comprarne continuamente di
nuovi l'economia circolari si occupa
della cosiddetta economia della
condivisione si sta discutendo molto in
europa di questo proprio in questa
settimana non è più tanto importante
possedere le cose è importante poterle
usare che è una cosa diversa
parlavi di economia circolare riguarda a
parlare alla fine della cosa più
importante significa parlare del cibo di
quello che mangiamo e qua un po
mi arrabbio sempre perché un terzo di
quello che noi produciamo per mangiare
non lo buttiamo via lo sprechiamo che
una parola sin troppo gentile per dire
che lo buttiamo via
noi ci rendiamo conto quando buttiamo
via un vasetto di yogurt scaduto
esattamente cosa stiamo buttando via
ovviamente se avete mai pensato un
vasetto di yogurt e materia e natura e
lavoro è energia e petrolio e saper fare
noi buttando via un vasetto di yogurt
scaduto
puntiamo via un pezzetto del futuro del
nostro pianeta
lo spreco alimentare è una condanna per
il nostro pianeta
anche perché gli scarti alimentari sono
una ricchezza infinita infinita vi
faccio un esempio solamente uno di poter
veramente fare tanti tutti quanti noi
conosciamo
l'olio extravergine di oliva olio questa
legge 20 oliva è molto buono e fa molto
bene fa molto bene perché contiene i
polifenoli che sono un potentissimo
antiossidante un anti cancro
fanno bene i polifenoli e viene noi
qualche anno fa
sino a qualche anno fa quando di tre o
quattro anni
la stragrande maggioranza di polifenoli
contenuti nelle olive li buttavamo via
era un rifiuto della produzione
dell'olio extravergine di oliva uno
scarto quando le olive vengono spremute
la prima spremitura si chiama acqua di
vegetazione viene buttata via
il 90 per cento di per i fenoli quelli
che ci fanno bene noi l'abbiamo sempre
buttati via
adesso abbiamo imparato a recuperarli e
sono tornati a disposizione del nostro
benessere
vi ho raccontato un po di storia
sull'economia circolare e non vi ho
detto nemmeno un numero è veramente
difficile parlare di economia senza
parlare di numero quindi alla fine di
questa storia meno un numero mi
consentirete rifarlo solamente uno è una
percentuale all 8,6 per cento 8,6 per
cento è la percentuale di economia
globale che oggi in questo momento
possiamo definire circolare è un numero
che possiamo leggere in due maniere
diverse
uno è veramente un numero basso stiamo
ancora sprecando energie risorse materie
che non abbiamo stiamo ancora rubando il
futuro alle prossime generazioni
ma questo numero così basso
lo puoi leggere anche in un altro modo è
un numero che apre una prateria di
innovazione di creatività di sviluppo di
capacità di cambiare le cose
la possibilità di creare l'infinito dal
finito la grande sfida dell'economia è
questa
l'economia circolari davvero l'unico
futuro possibile e da un futuro portata
di tutti tutti noi dobbiamo fare la
nostra parte pensiamoci ogni volta che
non chiudiamo rubinetto dell'acqua
quando ci laviamo i denti che non
spegniamo la luce che prendiamo la
macchina senza pensare ad una
alternativa
ogni volta che sprechiamo risorse noi
buttiamo via un pezzetto del futuro del
mondo
noi siamo chiamati ad esso ad una grande
sfida la sfida più importante che ha
investito la mia generazione
la possibilità di costruire il futuro il
futuro esiste solo se noi lo sappiamo
costruire l'economia circolare è lo
strumento che ci permette a tutti di
costruire il futuro
quindi cerchiamo di essere tutti un
pochino più circolari lo chiedo anche a
nome del mio scoglio perché se va avanti
così
il mio scoglio tra qualche anno arriva a
casa mia bussa alla porta e il caffè
sono vere a prendere lui nella mia
cucina buon futuro circolare a tutti
grazie